pour beaucoup d'entre vous un lycée
hôtelier
c'est ça à blois le lycée des métiers de
l'hôtellerie et du tourisme
c'est ça ça et ça allait on se calme
direction la cuisine
mais surprise on y parle ni de
papillotes ni le cow boy
d'un point de vue urbanistique quelles
sont les informations vous avez pu
obtenir auprès de la mairie concernant
justement le cadastre
contrairement aux apparences top
comprise ce ne sont pas deux futurs
chefs qui sont ici mais des futurs
managers et à l'endroit même où l'on
pourra trouver un pavé de rumsteck on
découvre un pavé de 240 pages un projet
d'entreprise ils vont peut-être créer un
jour leur entreprise ou au moins devenir
manager directeur assistant de direction
chef d'equipe pourquoi pas à travers ses
créations d'entreprises virtuelles
nous travaillons en collaboration avec
mes collègues d'économie droit gestion
il pensait entreprises on réfléchisse
entreprises on dormait entrouvrir
c'était tout le temps et reprise
d'entreprise
c'est moi c'est vraiment la création de
a à z et du début jusqu'à la fin ils
n'ont plus qu'à le faire en vrai météo
responsables de restauration doit
connaître les cuisines celle de
l'administration fiscale ainsi que celle
des pianos et des casseroles donc
objectif aulas et de tester des
associations des cuissons des dressages
des présentations et pendant ce temps là
à la cafétéria
on parle business et bénéfices après
faut les payer mais on les paye près de
40 50 % du prix de revente du prix d'un
euro
en fait non il ya un fournisseur de
toques et après c'est notre société qui
et qu'il augmente la toque ouais pas
facile à comprendre
mais revenons-en puisque justin loin de
la comptabilité du droit des salariés et
du cadastre est en pleine création mode
samoussas alors là si une garniture à
base de carottes oignons champions
je vais faire des samoussas avec que je
lance 8 frire pour faire un petit
garniture dans l'assiette c'est très
sympa c'est bon bienvenue dans mon
restaurant un restaurant un peu ses
ministres onomique ce que j'aime bien en
attendant les conseils avisés du chef
sont bienvenus vous avez vu qu'il ya eu
un sens dans le chou évidemment le côté
extérieur le plus beau est là le côté
intérieur qui est creux c'est moins beau
ça c'est comme quand vous travaillez vos
poissons le côté marron à l'intérieur le
côté le plus blanc à l'extérieur demain
deuxième épisode
l'implication des élèves et étudiants
dans la vie du lycée
attention soirée de gala